normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
military.com says dozens of troops
suspected of advocating overthrow of US
Government Pentagon extremism report
says uh what they're likely saying is
that they found 183 people who posted
things like get woke go broke and I
don't want to serve a woke military but
you know let's re would they actually
say there's that dude that got booted
cuz he was a communist too a couple
years back oh yeah remember that he had
the hat and said communism will win an
annual Pentagon report on extremism
within the ranks reveals that 78 service
members were suspected of advocating for
the overthrow of the US government and
another 44 were suspected of engaging or
supporting terrorism the report released
Thursday by the defense department
insector General revealed that in fiscal
2023 there were 183 allegations of
extremism across all branches of
military broken down not only into
efforts to overthrow the government and
terrorism but also advocating for
widespread discrimination or violence to
achieve political goals widespread
discrimination yo that sounds like some
guy might be like well go broke I'm like
ah there you go he advocating for
discrimination because only their rules
apply he emailed like four people so it
was widespread y he contacted enough 11
people there's 103 allegations or what
there's dozens 183 there's dozens of
people they've identified so how many
fed plants did it take to find them
faking like they were going to set up a
coup right that's what happened in
Michigan if there 3 allegations and they
found 78 service members then you know
you do the math few hundred 105 that are
feds it's got to be so the allegation
like well yeah but that's not a real one
cuz that guy was a Fed he was just
goting people into say F exception
because technically people in the
military are already feds and he
overthrowing the agents inside the
federal agency but advocating for the
overthrow of the government is that just
what counts is that is it saying that
Trump actually won in 2020 uh you know
it could be an FBI agent emailing a dude
like hey want to overthrow and then the
guy's like just puts a thumbs up emoji
on this on the question like it could be
that he agreed it's probably even more
innocuous than that it's like three
dudes are sitting in a room playing Call
of Duty and then the fat just goes you
know it' be cool if like like Trump
actually got rid of Biden right like
yeah sure whatever dude or they say
nothing that's it we got him they didn't
say no they just don't even respond to
it he's like well they didn't say no to
it so that's agreement dude I'm thinking
of the business plot SM Smedley Butler
500,000 troops about to March on
Washington DC like they're talking about
50 7 guys you kidding me no I think the
bigger story here is not that there's
extremists who want overthrow the
government it's that the US military is
basically weeding out anybody who
believes in this country and so what I
see as being more likely here is the
troops they're accusing of sedition or
whatever or of like they're essentially
accusing people of sedition are probably
like regular Americans who are like hey
man you know we got serious problems
with corruption Donald Trump tried to
withdraw troops from Syria and they
blocked him yeah Joe Biden's son's on an
energy board in Ukraine where we have
troops what the hell's going on and if
you say things like that they're they're
going to get mad about it they're going
to call you an extremist they're going
to look look what military.com they
posted was his Patriot front they posted
a photo of patriot front to refer to
these US troops now look don't get me
wrong some of these guys might be
Communists too like Phil brought up
there was that one viral story about the
guy what was it he like went to West
Point yeah he was uh he would would
would have been a a as a graduate of
West Point he would have been an officer
and he had a shirt that said communism
will win or no
was in his hat or something was in his
hat and then he held his hat to the
camera yeah he held his hat and he did
the the fist up and you know so he's
still on Twitter he's very lowkey and uh
and stuff but I follow him they
discharged him yeah he got booted so I I
see what what's going on and uh uh in
the US with the woke left and I just
think they 70 there like a 70% overlap
with Nazis and and and the left I mean
the hatred of Jews is absurd the
conspiracy theories the racial uh
segregationist policies the collectivist
action the use of symbols it's like
almost the same thing the whole of the
like World War II was the left fighting
the left and they drew America in it was
the Communists and the Nazis fighting
which is they're both statist both
collectivist and the United States is
based on liberal principles which put
the individual first they drug us into
their BS European garbage War they got
FDR to go fascist he got rid of the gold
standard he basically made this country
super fascist all this money there
there's an argument that and I generally
have a bad a negative opinion of FDR but
there is an argument to be made that
I've heard people make that is
compelling that is FDR was existed in a
time when socialism was very socialism
and and big government was
was it was omnipresent it was ascendant
it was everywhere and the policies that
and the argument that that people make
Pro FDR is that the policies that FDR
put into place the the social safety
nets actually prevented the United
States from turning into an actual
socialist country they were you know
they were things that obviously liberals
and and libertarian minded people don't
approve of but the point wasn't intended
to get more power to the government
because they the they wanted to get more
power to the government but it was to
prevent the people from turning the
United States into a socialist
government now I'm not sure that that
the argument is compelling to me I'm not
sure that I buy it but I've I've heard
it and you know at least it's it at
least it's like well okay that makes
sense when you think of the context of
the the whole world the whole Western
World at least in the in the 30s and and
40s you know it was like that that was
when you know big government and stuff
was really having its kind of hating
yeah Great Depression 1929 and then all
these governments are reeling all over
the planet like how do we get how do we
come back from this Banker incept like
what did the bankers cause that I don't
really know but I'm sure I wouldn't be
surprised if the same guys that built
the Federal Reserve that tried to
overthrow FDR in 1933 with the business
plot that that made the Bankers Trust in
1903 like these Bankers JP Morgan
Rockefeller Paul warberg all these dudes
if they were involved with with with
trying with causing the Great Depression
in order to buy the country up right
after that and maybe they wanted to be
fascism FDR was like no it's going to be
socialist those are the conspiracy
theories that wouldn't surprise me at
all because it was like fascism or
Socialism or die it was one or the other
like you either want massive Central Co
corporate Co-op or you want I don't know
what's the hell the other option is
socialism social systems but without
theism like less less corporations
centralized control I I I you know these
arguments about left and right and you
know communist and fascist don't matter
all that much it's authoritarian versus
libertarian for the most part it's
centralized versus decentralized and so
whatever whatever they claim the far
right to be is meaningless because it
doesn't actually describe what their
concern is their concern is other and
then when we say farle it doesn't
actually actually describe for the most
part our concerns because the concern is
centralization of power among anybody
could be corporations it could be
government
officials well there you go I guess I
just you it thank you yeah you hit the
you got the 100 yeah man centralization
is no joke I mean it is you can see the
power of it in Mass mobilization appeal
but then you look at Kim Jong-un sitting
all alone in his his palace with all the
authority in the world and the women
aren't having sex well not in the world
just just in North Kore can't make those
girls get pregnant no it's it's actually
simple it's because they want to be with
with him oh maybe that's right they're
all saving themselves hoping that one
day you know honestly that that could be
a component especially of of centralized
dictatorship with a cult of personality
there could be a lot of women hoping
that they get chosen so they want to be
pure and that results in a trend in
their culture there's also the
possibility I mean that
allegedly if I understand correctly
there's a lot of starvation going on in
North Korea and if you can't keep
yourself alive because you can't get
enough food It's probably hard to get
pregnant too yeah if anyone that has a
girlfriend or a wife would know that if
she's hungry that's about that's about
where it ends right there I mean yeah
some f if she's hungry you're not
getting laid true but I was more
thinking about the biological process of
of actually building the human being
inside the womb you starts there but
yeah you know Snickers cuz she ain't the
same when she's hungry and you ain't
getting none you want yourself yeah but
I don't know going back to the
military.com stuff with the the claims
about I mean it's a sensationalist
headline suspected of advocating
overthrow of US Government probably is
some dude on his computer being like man
this this Administration sucks somebody
should remove Joe Biden whatever yeah
whatever it is it's just about it's
we're going into an election year you
know there's there's less than a year
until the the election and the the
government wants the the media being an
in my opinion an arm of the government
they want people to be afraid of Donald
Trump you know the way they were at have
you have you seen those videos where
it's like Joe Scarboro yeah like Trump's
gonna make Rachel mattow he's going to
try and execute us like Rachel Mano
actually suggested Donald Trump will
will have them executed I see so that
stuff freaks me out because they project
right like they project what they're
what they really want to do and like you
know they're imprisoning us they one you
are 100% accurate it's freaky it it
freaks me out when they start talking
like that and accusing him a it yeah I
don't get it well what what what what is
that the new poll do you think with
Democrats win in 2024 they'll start
executing their political
opponents I mean look there are there
are definitely people on both sides that
are at that point where they're like
look look it's just time to start
cutting people up you know I'm sure
scary I mean yeah I think there's always
people like that but yeah but like the
question is if they are projecting and
saying that Donald Trump wants to
execute them is that a projection of
them suggesting we have to do it
otherwise they'll do it to us I mean
that's where that stuff leads the you
get these videos we talked about like
Pearl Davis and and and the manosphere
stuff they you have all these guys being
like nope every man in the world would
cheat on their wives and it's like
you're just saying you would like you're
saying you would you're saying in your
mind if you experienc this you would
cheat on your wife not everyone is like
you so when they scream Donald Trump is
going to do this stuff to us what
they're really saying is we'd do it if
we had the power and if they get the
power they'll do it to us because they
view that as the path forward I strongly
agree with that sentiment people tend to
believe other people are going to do
what they would do given the
circumstances why do they think this
about Donald Trump is it CU he said he
wants revenge the word it's
projection hint I don't think Trump said
Revenge he said retribution right
retribution yeah so the issue is the
reason why there are these guys that are
advocating this idea where if every guy
was given the opportunity to cheat on
their wife they would yeah I saw that
one push the button it's in their mind
in their mind they can't see a
circumstance in which they personally
would feel differently they can't
empathize or comprehend another person
might be like no I would not do that and
it's so shocking the the feeling in them
is so strong the desire to cheat on
their wives that they can't imagine any
other man could resist that urge to
cheat on their wives which is it's it's
it's insane because not only are you
talking about a guy not being able to
control whether you know how horny he is
to not cheat on his wife but that no guy
has the Integrity honor or force of will
I think part of that part of that with
the whole like people that are just like
oh you know they would it's because
they've never had the opportunity to
like if you're a guy that's like in a
situation where you get one girl and
that's like you you landed her and you
don't you know you don't get second
looks very much and and you're not
particularly they're also saying never
found one you know that you're just like
oh yeah I would totally because well
that's that's like I would never have
the opportunity you know outside of this
one particular situation that I have and
if I was presented with the opportunity
it would be such it's such a rare thing
I I don't feel like I could control
myself and say no if you have options
you're kind of like H I don't want to
mess up the good thing it's it's it's
also suggesting that these guys who are
saying this never met someone they truly
loved maybe and so they're just like
these people don't matter that much to
me I would of course break my word but
I'm not trying to get into that
conversation my point is this feeling
within people they cannot imagine
thoughts outside of their perspective so
when Rachel mat says Trump will arrest
and execute Us in her mind she's
thinking about how she would feel with
that power and in her mind she would
arrest and execute Donald trump it is
projection something they believe humans
are capable because they're capable of
it when I'm trying to empathize with
someone that thinks differently than me
first thing I do is I visualize them
with a blank slate not literally a blank
slate but like there is no emotions
before I try and visualize what they're
feeling I have to let go of what I'm
feeling that's the first step if you
just try and feel what they're feeling
your your emotions are already present
so you have to blank blank it you have
to get rid of it and then you can kind
of start to think it could be anything
what they're going through thanks for
watching in this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net